let's listen to the prime minister
by the news
that had from Balmoral
the death of her majesty the queen is a
huge shock to the nation and to the
world
Queen Elizabeth II was the rock on which
modern Britain was built
our country has grown and flourished
under her reign
Britain is the great country it is today
because of her
she ascended the throne just after the
second World War
she championed the development of the
Commonwealth from a small group of seven
countries to a family of 56 Nations
spanning every continent of the world
we are now a modern thriving Dynamic
Nation
through second thing
Queen Elizabeth II provided us with the
stability and the strength that we
needed
she was the very Spirit of Great Britain
and that spirit will endure
she has been our longest ever reigning
monarch
it's an extraordinary achievement to
have presided with such dignity and
Grace for 70 years
her life of service
stretched Beyond most of our living
memories
in return she was loved and admired by
the people in the United Kingdom and all
around the world
she has been a personal inspiration to
me
and to many britons
her Devotion to duty is an example to us
all
earlier this week at 96 she remained
determined to carry out her duties as
she appointed me as her 15th prime
minister
throughout her life she's visited more
than a hundred countries and she has
touched the lives of millions around the
world
in the difficult days ahead we will come
together with our friends across the
United Kingdom the Commonwealth and the
world to celebrate her extraordinary
lifetime of service
it is a day of great loss
but Queen Elizabeth II leaves a great
legacy
today the crown passes
as it has done for more than a thousand
years
to our new monarch our new head of state
his majesty King Charles III
with the King's family we mourn the loss
of his mother
and as we mourn we must come together as
a people to support him
to help him bear the awesome
responsibility that he now carries for
us all
we offer him our loyalty and devotion
just as his mother devoted so much to so
many for so long
and with the passing of the second
Elizabethan Age We usher in a new era in
the Magnificent history of our great
country
exactly as her majesty would have wished
by saying the words God Save the King